mind your decisions I'm crushed Oh
Walker what is the value of the
following infinite product the first
term is e over the square root of e this
is multiplied by the cube root of e over
the fourth root of e this is multiplied
by the fifth root of e over the sixth
root of e and this pattern continues
infinitely I think a viewer in India for
suggesting this problem pause the video
if you'd like to give it a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this problem
[Music]
we'll get started by converting the enth
roots into exponent form
next the exponents in the denominators
will be negative values as all of these
have the same base we can put them all
together the result will be e to the
power of the alternating harmonic series
what's the value of this exponent recall
that the natural log of 1 plus X is
equal to X minus x squared over 2 plus X
cubed over 3 and so on this is true for
X greater than negative 1 and X less
than or equal to 1 substitute X is equal
to 1 and we get the alternating harmonic
series is equal to the natural log of 2
that's the value of the exponent so we
have e to the power of the natural log
of 2 which of course is equal to 2 the
answer is 2 good thanks for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]